let's talk about a guy in public service
who is doing great work a guy who is
saying i will not participate in the lie
a guy who is saying i do not want to
rule over my citizens a guy who is
saying
it is time for people to live life
freely and a guy who's also saying
enough with this mainstream media bs
the guy i'm talking about of course is
ron desantis and he was interviewed by
my fast-talking small jewish friend ben
shapiro take a look well i think it's
just a matter of just understanding kind
of what time it is now if this was a
media that was dedicated to fact factual
reporting gathering facts putting it out
then you know you may want to behave a
little bit differently but in fact i
mean they're highly partisan and not
only are they highly partisan they
really are detached from reality and
from facts at this point their main goal
is to pursue their narratives and so if
you have facts that undercut their
narratives they are either going to
ignore those facts or actively try to
smother those facts and so that's just
where we're at and so these corporate
outlets
you know i think in terms of what
they've done to their reputations with
the russia collusion report they were
manufacturing that whole story they gave
each other pulitzer prizes for reporting
on a false conspiracy theory and so if
you had asked me 10 years ago about the
media i wouldn't have said they were our
friend but i'd say you know they have a
liberal bias you got to be careful of
that but but now you just got to
understand those corporate outlets are
so untethered from the truth they are so
highly partisan uh that that's the way
you have to you have to treat them and
so when they're trying to pursue
narratives
i don't let them get away with it if
they're trying to just get information
to try to do a hit piece i don't let
them get away with it and the thing is
is when you have the facts on your side
it's very difficult for them because a
lot of them all they do is recycle
whatever the narrative de jure of the
day is but i would say republicans have
to understand you know don't try to get
these people to like you okay that's not
what they're going to do
i love it i love it like what else is
there he's just telling you the truth
the media is in it for a narrative the
media is in it with democrats
republicans often fall in this uh really
bad trap of they say something
that's a little bit sort of anti-trump
or anti-republican then the media starts
liking them so then they start doing
more and more of it
that's the stuff that we need to hear
more of what we just heard right there
from ron desantis stop playing with
these people you know i don't care
anymore actually when i get now email i
get emails all the time mainstream media
things that want to interview me or
report on me and usually we just ignore
them or we send a one-line decline back
like it doesn't matter
i think at this point these things are
so corrupt these institutions are so
deeply corrupt the new york times the
washington post cnn msnbc all of the
stuff that in essence if they are
writing something you can almost
assuredly believe that the opposite is
true not an absolutely every incident
it's an incident and there is some sort
of like sliding scale there right so
like there's certain things that they're
always going to lie about things related
to race anything that they can make
democrats look good it doesn't mean that
they're going to lie to you completely
about an earthquake in indonesia right
like that one is like they can sort of
put that one on the side but when they
try to destroy someone for being racist
when they try to say that someone said
the most horrible thing you could
possibly imagine and it sounds exactly
like the type of thing we would expect
that person to say because that person's
horrible with the bad ideas you can
pretty much assume it's a lie so i think
what is happening right now which is
quite beautiful
is that as mainstream media dies and
more independent shows arise
say perhaps like this one that more and
more people will just say well who cares
what cnn said cnn said something well
jim acosta is a buffoon wolf blitzer is
a robot you know don lemon's a clown
like why would i listen to these people
they're all democrat operatives and we
all know it so we need to just stop
playing ball with those things and that
would become entirely consistent with my
view of build new things right build new
things once once these guys are out of
the way and they'll never really go away
there's so much money behind it i mean
think about msnbc you know when i talk
about joy reid and these these races
that they put on msnbc every day think
about the money that is funded behind
that like msnbc nbc's in there this is a
giant
conglomerate corporate monstrosity why
is it that this giant thing who are the
network executives there that hire these
people to put them on air to tell you
that you're racist why would they do
that like we have to start on thinking
about all of these things at multiple
levels and i could harken this back to
the first story which is as horrific
as what just happened in wisconsin is
the next step of the story is what the
media will do with it and again it is
your job to make sure that the media
can't drop it because they want to drop
it and it's your job to make sure that
when they're lying that you make sure
that the people around you know that a
lie is actually a lie